the year 2021 is nearly at a close i've
been seeing a lot of people doing recaps
of what they did or what happened to
them or
other similar things for 2021 and i
thought about that and i said well i'll
do a
video about that and i'm not going to
talk about what's coming up in 2022 i'll
probably do a separate video about that
i just thought it'd be kind of an
interesting idea to look back over
the year and there's a lot of stuff to
talk about as i went through and saw the
various things that i've done or that
i've been involved in over the last year
and some of them might be things that
you could be interested in and haven't
learned about because i'm kind of spread
out in a lot of different places so if
that's the case you can click the show
more video description below and there
will be links to all these different
things but
i'll just lead you through it right now
running through things in
you could say no particular order
although i do have them written down for
myself as notes so the first thing i
thought i would start with is i've been
now married for 10 years to andy shaka
my my wife
and we had our 10-year wedding
anniversary back in november you might
have seen that in social media
and just a few days ago we had a
different kind of anniversary so andy
and i have known each other since 1985
when she was a freshman and i was a
sophomore
in high school at catholic memorial back
in you know a long time ago and we
you know we we knew each other back then
we crossed paths again in the 90s then
we sort of you know as everybody does
lost track of each other
and we reconnected through facebook in
um
well 12 years ago
so
you know in in the very end of
2009 i'd been getting facebook
suggestions you know you should send a
friend request to this person for a
couple of months actually longer than
that and i remembered the name and i
remembered her as being somebody pretty
cool and so finally i
sent out a friend request and she
answered and that's how we actually
reconnected through facebook we started
writing each other back and forth found
we had all these common interests
eventually fell in love and then after
that after actually deciding that we
were going to get together and get
married we began talking on the phone at
a distance so there's a whole story to
be told there but you know suffice it to
say we've been together for you know a
long
time and we've also been back here in
the city of milwaukee which is not
actually where both of us grew up we
both grew up west of here andy a little
bit west me a little bit further west
out in the styx which is now
pretty developed
but we've been here in the downtown of
milwaukee uh six years we came here with
two dogs and a cat
we still uh have you know the one cat
left
sassy who is 19 years old
and you know she's also doing pretty
good this last year spent a lot of time
spending time with the sassy cat she now
sleeps most of the day downstairs in the
kids bunk bed
but you know she's pretty old so she's
doing pretty good you may have seen
pictures of me taking her outside on the
deck or other places and that's that's
us the little household now me and andy
and sassy
i've also gotten to see my oldest
daughter who lives up here
part of the time in milwaukee going to
university of wisconsin milwaukee
and you know so that that's been nice as
well
another cool thing about this year is
i've been getting in quite a bit of
regular exercise
and i have gone from
about 300 pounds down to 270 pounds
which is good you know for the
circulatory system and my knees and
everything else and that has been
through
adding a good bit of muscle and getting
rid of a lot of fat because i've been
doing the weight circuit and taking long
walks those are the majority of the
exercise i did go to a few aqua zumba
classes with andy but that wasn't really
my sort of thing so it's it's all mostly
just the weight circuit and and these
nice long walks that you may have seen
pictures from
and
what else um you know i i did academic
teaching this year
i actually taught i think
10 or 11 classes
i'll start with matc because that is in
some respects
you know i'm changing things up with
that so matc is milwaukee area technical
college which the main campus is is
about five blocks walk from here and i
finished up teaching for them i
in the
in the
spring i was teaching two classes for
them intro to philosophy online and i
was teaching in the second chance pell
program which is for
prisoners here in wisconsin i was
teaching ethics for that
and then i also taught an ethics class
in the summer and then i decided i i
don't really want to teach for matc
anymore in part because you know they
they don't pay very well and
they're kind of dysfunctional that's
that's the subject for a whole other
conversation so i just tapered off
teaching for them
i am still teaching for carthage college
which is down in kenosha but i teach
only online for them as well i i'm not
driving down to carthage and i'm not um
you know spending time on on campus
but um you know i i did teach two
classes for them
an intro to philosophy class and then a
business ethics a class that i've been
teaching for them quite a bit
and i think that's probably the last
business ethics class i'm going to teach
because things have been moving around
in the curriculum
and so now the business ethics class i'm
sort of like having to answer to two
different masters and i've decided i'm
not going to do that one anymore
instead i've been focusing a lot more on
milwaukee institute of art and design
which is the main place that i teach
every semester i teach two classes there
and then i teach a summer class so i'm
not full-time but i'm you know teaching
a pretty significant load there and
that's the cool place to teach they they
want me to teach innovative classes
and to develop them they trust me you
know a lot more you could say as a
instructor with 20 years plus of
experience
and this year it's going to be 10 years
of experience teaching online classes so
what have i taught for them well i
taught intro to philosophy in the summer
and then i also taught ethics for
artisan designers i i got to teach a new
class on ursula k le guin's earth-sea
books
i taught my philosophy mindfulness in
life which is basically a philosophy as
a way of life kind of class and then
philosophies of human nature and other
one of my staples so you know all told
looking at it i did teach in fact 10
classes this last
year
what else a lot of stuff with modern
stoicism and stoic philosophy you may
know that i
co-edited a
book that just recently came out
stoicism today selected writings volume
three it's me and leah goldrick who
edited that that was a really big
project that was funded by
a patron and the proceeds of which go to
the modern stoicism organization so
that's really cool
andy shaka and i also did something
really big this year we organized and
ran
the international stoicon conference
that was a lot of moving parts to it
and
it was it was pretty cool we did all
these things before it we've got videos
from it again you know click the links
below and you'll be taken to where you
can find all that sort of stuff i also
did some presentations at stoicon x's
i was invited to give a presentation for
stoic on x military
i did a presentation for stoicon x
norway
with andy i did a joint presentation
stoicon x uh paths to flourishing about
stoicism and marriage and there was the
marcus aurelius anniversary as well so i
did a presentation on that for the new
acropolis chicago
um i also you know i'm the editor of the
stoicism today blog
and i brought on a friend and colleague
to be the assistant editor
and that went really well and we are you
know i'm getting so much more done
having somebody to help me out
so that's that's been quite good
and i also developed a class on stoic
philosophy in addition to the epictetus
and caribbean class that i've had out
there for quite a while
i developed one for a platform called
listenable called basics of stoic
philosophy
and practice it's a really cool short
audio course
you can listen to it free if you want to
i think for seven days i'll put a link
to that below
as well
i also did some academic conferences
all of which were online nothing face to
face
i gave a paper at the saint anselm
conference which was based at saint
anselm college
in new hampshire but of course was was
online and we had an international crowd
doing that so that was really cool um
and then we we harold and i uh the guy
that i use my my assistant editor he and
i also did a presentation on pro races
in the aristotelian and stoic traditions
for the aristotle and the aristotelian
tradition conference and then both of us
actually teamed up again and did another
presentation on priorasis and epictetus
recently at the second brazilian
epictetus seminar and i should say
something about collaboration
i've got a few people that i do
collaborative work with you know i
mentioned my co-editor for stoicism
today leah and then harold is is a
somebody who i do a lot of work with i
also have a friend and colleague down in
south africa mark smith and we do some
collaborative stuff and then there's
other collaborative things that i do
that i'll get to talking about in just a
bit
i think it's worth spending some time
talking about the
youtube channel as well
not least since i'm
putting this out on youtube right
so
something really cool we passed the 100
000 subscribers mark earlier this year
on youtube and you know i've been on
youtube producing videos now for 10
years so that is
kind of cool you know to have that
footprint as they call it a digital
footprint or presence out there i think
there's a lot of people who
have benefited from these philosophy and
other videos that i do
and it's cool to see that you know
despite not putting a lot of
work into technical production and and
more just you know the thought the
content
people want that and and it's working um
we also did
a number of important videos in series
so
46 half hour hegel videos over the
course of the year
70 leguin earthsea videos and the new
speculative fiction studies
i also did some speculative fiction
studies
work on philip jose farmers the lovers
i did nine sadler's stories the most
recent of which i released just earlier
this week i remastered ten of the
epictetus and coridian videos and i have
some more of those to do i did nine
sadler's honest book reviews
i also did eight classic metal classes
with another collaborator of mine scott
tarrouli guitar professor at berkeley
school of music and a good friend and
fellow metalhead i did nine worlds of
speculative fiction videos which also
then
included live chat and
some
follow-up in video conferencing
continuing that series
you can also find videos for 20 wisdom
for life radio shows that another
collaborator of mine dan hayes and i
did this year
for riverwest radio a community radio
station here
in town and i also did um about 20 about
250
sadler's lectures and sadler shorts
podcasts
um
so that's you know some some other
presents we did a lot of cool events
amas every month
live readings from my book reason
fulfilled by revelation i shot a lot of
other kind of funny videos like the
wombo art generator ones or these
twitter conversations where somebody
like richard dawkins kind of stepped in
it captioned contests we did quite a few
of those unboxing videos and evil sadler
even showed his head so lots and lots of
video and podcast production
um what else um
i uh
i did the radio show wisdom for life but
i've also started coming on
every other week on wednesdays onto the
drive time from riverwest radio show and
that's kind of a whole different format
you know that's more
short news stories and commentary and
interviewing people and that's been a
lot of fun
so i'm really glad the station manager
asked me to after coming on for a few
interviews myself to become a regular
co-host for that
i've done a lot of podcast interviews
also some video and site interviews this
year a lot of people have been asking me
to come on their shows or you know their
podcasts and so that's been a lot of fun
as well
and then
you know a good bit of my work is
in addition to doing the public
philosophy
and the academic work and you know
stoicism today
i also have clients
and i have done a lot of work this year
with tutorials philosophical counseling
consulting academic coaching
i have been very bad about doing any
sort of marketing or promotion and
people are seeking me out instead which
is really great so i'm blessed in that
respect
and i've just been a very very busy guy
this year and i'm i'm happy that i'm
able to do this all almost all from home
which is uh
quite amazing for me and you know we're
living in a beautiful place
here in the downtown of milwaukee great
location
and so it's been a pretty good year i
would say
overall
you